la crise est passée mais les
chancelleries du monde entier sont
encore sous le choc
et pour les observateurs étrangers il
s'agit surtout d'un remarquable déclin
de l'homme fort de la Russie dans une
interview au journal La Provence
Emmanuel Macron a souligné les divisions
qui existent selon lui au sein du campus
outre atlantique Anthony blinken n'a pas
manqué de réagir sur les plateaux télé
ce dimanche il y a 16 mois les forces
russes étaient aux portes de Kiev en
Ukraine croyant qu'elle prendrait la
capitale dans quelques jours et réairait
le pays de la carte en tant qu'État
indépendant aujourd'hui la Russie doit
défendre Moscou sa capitale contre des
mercenaires qu'elle a elle-même créé
les alliés de l'Ukraine suivent la
situation de près les États-Unis le
Royaume-Uni l'Allemagne et la France ont
renouvelé leur soutien indéfectible à
Kiev
même évoqué la crise lors d'un échange
téléphonique ce dimanche un peu plus
tard dans la soirée le président
ukrainien a fortement insisté sur
l'échec subit par Poutine
plus l'agression russe dure plus elle
dégrade la Russie elle-même l'une des
manifestations de cette dégradation et
que l'agression russe se retourne contre
elle lors de nos conversations avec les
dirigeants nous avons échangé nos
évaluations de ce qui se passe en Russie
nous voyons la situation de la même
manière et savon comment y répondre
affaibli aux yeux des Occidentaux le
régime russe peut toutefois compter sur
le soutien de Pékin en tant que voisin
amical et partenaire stratégiques la
Chine soutient la Russie dans ses
efforts pour protéger la stabilité du
pays a déclaré le ministère chinois des
Affaires étrangères qualifiant la
mutinerie d'affaires intérieure
au lendemain de cette tentative de
rébellion la retraite de Wagner et
l'exil de son chef geni Prigogine sont
présentés par les médias russe comme une
victoire du Kremlin mais le pouvoir
russe a bien montré ses faiblesses au
monde entier